[Music]
when building a great company when
building a big company every single
position matters meaning the CEO matters
see a Fermata CEO matter CMO matters
every play every position matters it's
very critical but there's a complete
different responsibility when somebody
is a founder let me explain to what it
is a founder has no one to turn to
there is nobody to say oh it was my
mistake it was your mistake you didn't
you don't everything is the founders
mistake everything a CFO can turn to the
CEO to need help if they made a mistake
a CEO can lean on a CFO president can
lean on CEO founder can't turn to
anybody nobody everything is the
founders fault so today in this episode
I'm going to cover with you 20 qualities
of a great founder and I want you to
keep this in mind everything I cover
with you doesn't mean there are not more
qualities or there are some exceptions
to the rule where somebody you met who
didn't have six of the qualities but you
will generally see a trend and say this
makes a lot of sense because that person
had this this person had this that
person at this or maybe you had it as
well and prior to me getting into it any
questions any thoughts about what I
cover today comment below and if you
haven't subscribe to the number one
channel on YouTube for entrepreneurs
click on the subscribe button the moment
we cross over a million subs we're gonna
have our first live conference I can't
wait to meet you at our first value
taming conference so many of you are
excited about it so let me get right
into it point number one great quality
of a founder number one they're very
unreasonable they are very demanding
because they're so unreasonable and
demanding a couple things happens one at
the beginning stages of them starting
their business they lose a few people
you know why because no one yet knows if
their rights or personal leaving them is
like listen I don't think you're gonna
make it why dude you're so unreasonable
you're so demanding you haven't even
done anything yet why are you expecting
so much for me what is wrong with you
the company's a small company why are
you so demanding that person doesn't
realize that the profit already sees
what they're going that the founder
already sees where he's going this
person doesn't see it but the great
founders they can't help themselves but
being unreasonably demanding point
number two others can coexist what a
great founder why coexist because
founder realizes listen I can either be
the celebrity guy and I run a small
little business of seven employees and
I'm so powerful or if I want to really
build a big business and scale it I have
to have other people that are smarter
then we coexist around me who are also
gonna give me directions in areas I know
nothing about nothing about which means
great founders allow other people to
coexist within them point number three a
level of determination higher than the
rest they're determined they're gonna
get it done it's kind of part of the
unreasonably demanding they are so
determined to get this thing done that
they end up getting it up point number
four nimble yet firm what do I mean by a
nimble yet firm look they're firm about
their beliefs but they're nimble about
having somebody else giving them
direction on how to do it better
hey what do you think about if we do
this what do you think about if we do
that what do you think about if we do
this
oh no problem let me try this part
they're nimble yet point number five
they don't get swayed let me explain to
what I mean by they don't get swayed
easily about their vision they are
positively stubborn there's a lot of
negative stubborn people in the world
that they're stubborn because they just
don't want to hear anything else these
guys are positively stubborn and
optimistic about the fact that this
thing's gonna become a reality which
means you can't sway them matter of fact
some people get upset when they try to
sway them I remember when we first
started a company I got so many calls
from relatives friends people that today
say para always supported you but they
did whatever they could to try to swing
me pat I don't know if it's a good idea
man you already have a good position
going on you're making three four
hundred thousand dollars you know why
would you change it do you know you're
going through you shouldn't be doing
everybody was trying to sway but I kind
of saw I know what we're going we're
gonna be pulling this thing off even
though it sounded crazy to a lot of
people positively stubborn it may sound
like initially negatively stubborn but
they know they're being positively
stubborn because they bought into a
vision that may not make sense to
everybody else that's why they were
founder point over six willing to share
equity within victories with others why
is that important
the bigger the talent you want the
bigger the piece they're gonna want and
the bigger the victory they're gonna
need to be a part of so if you want me
to let go my great job that I have an
amount of salary I have in profit
sharing a 401k you want me to come and
run with you mr. founder I want a bigger
piece of victory later on no problem I
understand founders who say no to it are
ones who don't have
big of a vision but founders that say
yes to it and they realize who this
person that's coming up and the talent
that they want they realize my vision is
so big that at much rather own 70% of a
billion dollar company than a hundred
percent of a hundred million dollar
company the math is completely different
I'd rather own 20 percent of a ten
billion dollar company than own or you
know a hundred percent of a five million
dollar company it's purely a
mathematical formula founders understand
I want a lot of strong talent for us to
build it as big as we want point number
seven willing to start all over again
from scratch what I mean by willing to
start all over again when they're not
afraid of losing everything people lead
better founders are okay because
founders realized I have to figure out
whether we can pull this off or not I'm
willing to start off you know start from
scratch again that that level of you
know determination of getting it and
realizing I may have to start all over
again gets respect from competitors gets
respect from talent gets respect from
their employees gets respect from their
customers gets respect from their
vendors because they say wow this guy is
really willing to push the envelope and
he's pretty determined he's certain what
he's doing
something's different about this guy the
only way great founders gonna be able to
build a big big company is at some point
you have to be willing to at this
breaking point where it's either sink or
swim they are not afraid of getting to
this point a lot of people are afraid
they play weight you say these guys are
now I'm willing to get it's okay your
skis saying I'm gonna die I'm okay with
that
but I'm gonna fight like hell to make
sure we make that and make it out of
this you know issue that we're facing
right now point number eight comfortable
having tough conversations with others
they're not uncomfortable sitting down
with a team member or a vendor or
partner or competitor or lawyer or
anybody and saying listen here's what
we're going through this is the
challenge we're facing I don't think I
like what's taking place right now tell
me about what's going on with your
department why is it that we had this
over here they don't have a problem
having a tough conversations because
they're believers of what taking place
with the company they're gonna have
those conversations with others point
number nine constantly selling you can't
help these guys but hear them sell 24/7
they don't if you told them stop selling
they don't even know what that means
because they're going to be selling 24/7
what they think their company is going
to be doing or their vision is going to
be doing point over ten integrity
integrity is very critical now I know a
lot of times people say well
person's a little bit you know a manaos
I don't know he kind of will go to the
gray area or he'll go to this area he'll
go to that area fine
other people want to say that no problem
people who stay with a founder for long
enough over time they know that person
may be crazy but there are certain
things they're not gonna cross if you
cross the line there how would you keep
the best talent how would you keep the
best smart people around you're just not
gonna do it if you struggle with
integrity you're gonna lose a lot of
people that is a quality so necessary I
think Warren Buffett said there's three
things he likes right energy integrity
and competency I think those were the
three things he says without integrity
forget the other two right I want to say
those are the three things that yet the
point is to build a big business you
need people around you to trust you just
as much as you trust them that requires
integrity great founders have that
number 11 good sounding board around
them to show them their flaws and faults
what I mean by that good founders have
people that tell them you're doing this
wrong you may want to reconsider this
and they're willing to listen to it
doesn't mean they take all the feedback
all the time but they're willing to
listen to and say that makes sense by
the way let me explain to what I mean by
this see in the mind of a founder
somebody sits there and says this makes
sense logically let's do it this makes
sense this makes sense no problem it's
not even now I'm taking anything
personal the founders gonna take
anything personal because the whole
thing is if what you're suggesting in my
brain clicks and it's gonna help us get
there faster I don't care who gets the
credit for it let's do it they're
willing to do it because it logically
makes sense for them to apply what the
feedback that's being given to them by
their advisory board around them number
12 Restless out-of-control energy it's
almost as if they never go to sleep
people always wondering how is this
person at 15 different places at the
same time I don't get it you were just
here how are you here this afternoon the
Restless they're going nonstop and that
part about being a restless founder a
lot of people look at and say wait a
minute I can't go out that pace or oh my
gosh he's always after trying to grow
what he's doing here I am so glad he's
on my side because I'm going against
that guy I've got to put that kind of
energy to go up against that guy I don't
know about that I'm okay doing what I'm
doing to be on his team
together going against a marketplace
versus me facing a guy like that point
over thirteen great recruiters they're
constantly recruiting they're recruiting
everybody and the reason why they're
constant recruiting everybody is because
they can't help themselves sell their
vision all the time everywhere dinner
movies text email videos articles blogs
it doesn't matter they are constantly
selling where they're going so they're
constantly recruiting great talent
because they keep telling the story over
and over and over and over again which
leads me to point number fourteen and
that is they're the Pied Piper
let me explain to what I mean by this
they're always converting people it's
almost like during the baptism game let
me baptize this guy from a non-believer
to a believer this guy doesn't believe
in what we're doing right now let me
make him a believer this audience I'm
speaking to watching none of them
believe in what we're doing right now
I'm gonna make every single one of them
a believer they're going around
evangelizing their message to the world
because they want to convert everybody
they want to convert everybody to
believe in that what they're talking
about is the truth and it's gonna become
a reality this sounds strange to you but
go find a founder and spend a day with
them and look what happened they do this
24/7 there in the converting business
and they're constantly baptizing people
into their vision and what they're going
next next point they learn how to
stretch the dollar a great founder
Lawrence how to stretch the dollar
because at the beginning you don't have
a lot of money so you got to figure out
a way to make this fifty thousand
dollars and make it seem like it's a
quarter million dollars you got to take
those hundred thousand dollars and turn
it into a million dollars got to take
this thousand dollars and make it
fifteen thousand dollars that's what
they do they're very good at stretching
the dollar and have it last longer next
gut feeling intuition this is not
something we can teach this is not
something I can read in a book and say
I've got a great gut feeling no no it's
a gut feeling I don't think this is a
good idea I don't feel this personal
good higher I don't feel good about this
person we're working I don't feel good
about this person we want to do business
but I don't know what it is I just don't
feel good about it I have a certain
intuition about this personally I don't
think this is a good idea you know how
mothers have certain intuition about
certain friends I have a
feeling about this I don't sense
anything that's how a founder has an
intuition about somebody to go into
business with or not to go into business
with next point point number 17 their
greater pain in the picture they're
constantly painting a picture of what's
possible if everybody comes together and
builds the business point number 18
they're very moody very moody but they
have perspective
let me explain to what I mean by they're
very moody but they have perspective
they could go from happy to pissed off
in a second and they'll still won't fire
you you could be sitting in a meeting
and you may be thinking it's over it's
done today 30 minutes later they come
talk to you as if nothing happening like
wait a minute you'd you would just
scream what what just like are you off
you were upset why are you laughing
telling a joke right now in the kitchen
what just happened there bro you are all
very you're saying that to themselves
founders have great perspective you know
why because they realize they need
people what do you think founders are
insane they're crazy thinking they don't
need the help of people of course they
know they need the help of people but
they can help themselves they can't help
themselves of not being Moody at times
because they are so urgent about this
thing becoming a reality that they
wanted to become a reality today and to
them it's gonna become a reality today
and so because of that everybody else is
always trying to catch up to their speed
that's where the moodiness comes from
okay because they don't get their ways
they sometimes they get Moody but they
have perspective so they may lose it but
they're gonna go back and be in fine
five minutes later sometimes even less
than it you'd be amazed how crazy this
when it happens next they have
imagination they're always in the
what-if world they're always an army oh
my gosh can you imagine if this takes
place what if we can pull this off so
people people gravitate toward somebody
that's always living in what if this
thing could takes place so so because
this is gonna sound crazy because
they're always in the imagination phase
of the future what is possible
they're also typically the people that
have the most anxiety or most panic
because they're always living in the
future this doesn't make a lot of sense
but they're always thinking about 10
years from now we're gonna be here five
years from now we're gonna be here oh my
gosh that gives me so much anxiety and
I'm boom that turns into urgency
determination to want to get it done and
all the other points come to you and
last but not least they have interesting
conversations with themselves this is
not self-talk I'm not talking about
you're amazing you're awesome this is so
great no no they're always talking to
themselves
you know why they're always talking to
themselves because at the beginning
there isn't anybody else they only
talked to themselves they have to talk
to themselves so the conversation they
have them with themselves themselves
becomes a board here what do you think
about this do you think we should do
this do you think we shouldn't do this
what about if this happens what if I've
that happens so it's always you don't
see this moment but this is moving all
the time it's always conversation
conversation conversation comes that
sounds crazy sounds insane but founders
are always talking to themselves what if
we go this or what if we go that kind of
like this guy what do you think about
that guy whatever so it's always talking
so you look at somebody you look at a
founder in their eyes who's gonna think
you're talking to themselves they're
thinking they're calculating everything
is going here everything is going here
so founders at this point if you're
listening to this you're probably
telling yourself this sounds more like a
crazy guy than it sounds like a founder
yes most founders are pretty crazy most
founders are pretty strange because for
somebody who's willing to put that kind
of pressure and insanity into their
lives you have to be a little bit off
you have to be and by the way please
understand this a founder isn't
necessarily the best most important
position in a company a founder is
simply the person that gives the company
an opportunity to survive a person could
come in that's a great CEO that could
take the company to a whole different
level that that found her by himself or
herself could have never done it could
have never done it he needed that CEO
she needed that CFO she needed that
operations guys she needed that CMO with
that that person kiss it goodbye but a
founder makes the company the
organization to society the city the
community the country make it through
the difficult phases and for that we
give the founder the credit of being a
founder so those are the 20 qualities of
great founders and by the way I want to
hear from you if you ever work with a
great founder you if you ever work with
a great founder that left a great
impression of you or maybe even
something that you learned that says
this was a little bit odd but he was
such a great founder I want to hear
about that send me a tweet at Patrick
mid David and tell me what was so
special about the founder that you work
with and by the way if you want a PDF
for all of this Mario always prepares a
PDF down below click on a link below and
go download the PDF for you to look at
and on one sheet of paper and say these
are the
qualities I'm good at these are the 13
qualities I'm good at and sometimes you
may be running a business yourself and
within a business you may be expanding
into a whole new market that the company
is going into you become the founder of
that new market that you're building and
exploring into you are a founder of that
new community because no one knows that
business yet it's like taking coca-cola
to Brazil before anybody knew Brazil
it's like taking a brand to country
before anybody new in that country what
that brand was you become a founder of
that country as well so right now some
of the qualities that you're good at and
circle them and a last but not least
again if you haven't subscribed to this
channel you click on this button here
and join the notification squad for
being one the first that gets the videos
when it comes down take everybody thanks
for watching bye bye